Vladimir Putin has said that mutual or
dual citizenship for both Russians and
Ukrainians would be a win-win situation
crane Ian's and Russians they are
brothers moreover I believe that this is
one nation with their cultural
linguistic and historical features but
it is in fact one nation if we have
joined citizenship both Russians and
Ukrainians will benefit well for more in
the story let's cross live now charities
Donnell quarter don relations between
Moscow and Kiev really have been
scraping the barrel the last number of
years soup so tell us how did this talk
of dual citizenship actually come about
well you know it all began last week at
the beginning of a back-and-forth of
statements between Vladimir Putin and
the newly elected ukrainian president
vladimir zalenski now Putin said that
Russia would fast-tracked applications
for Russian passports made by residents
of the people's republics of lugansk
ends and yet now these Ukrainian
territories decided to declare
independence from the western-backed
Kiev government after Euro Maidan in
2014 he later said that this perhaps
would extend to all Ukrainians and
zolensky responded to the Putin
statement actually he said that the
Kremlin shouldn't try to seduce
Ukrainians into Russia and that his ruse
and he gave a tit-for-tat response about
that we will provide Ukrainian
citizenship to people of all nations who
suffer from authoritarian and corrupt
regimes first and foremost to Russians
who are suffering today almost more than
most those stats don't really back up
zelinsky's claim about Russian suffering
though since Euro my done over 2.5
million Ukrainians have moved to Russia
in search of work
asylum citizenship all those things and
that's in comparison to the 126
Ukrainian passport recipients last year
who were of Russian origin
but today's Putin's statement clearly
set made it clear that the Kremlin sees
a mutual citizenship between the two
countries as a way to solve real
suffering in the region Arty's Donal
quarter are taking us through that
you